salut tout le monde le podcast
d'aujourd'hui est présenté par fs a eu
l'aval la faculté des sciences de
l'administration de l'université laval
puis je pense sérieusement je voulais
faire des petits cours à distance à la
faculté des sciences démonstration de
mercy laval parce que la semaine passée
on ne sut andrée marquis quelqu'un c'est
ma part les autres pannes à riols un
petit peu plus deep le belge a manqué
des buts puis je suis sensé est
entrepreneur dans vie accueillie je
pense qu'un petit problème parce que des
petites formations le en gestion qui en
entrepreneuriat ça serait pas de tordre
puis fsu de laval en fait l'université
laval et à québec et non à laval mais ça
veut pas dire que si vous n'êtes pas
québec vais pas participer à des
formations de fait suer laval parce que
y offre depuis plus de 25 ans des cours
en ligne qui sont montés pourra être
faits en ligne si on peut juste pris un
cours présentiels pour le transformer
ces décors qui sont faits pour être en
ligne
donc si vous voulez plus d'informations
sur les différents programmes de
microprogramme jusqu'à m billet que vous
qu'ils sont accessibles en fuite avait
fait cela va aller voir le lien dans la
d'esprit du podcast et vous allez avoir
toutes les informations nécessaires
merci la gagne 2 fse laval pour
commanditer le podcast hier le podcast
de cette semaine et présenté par
mindscape
encore une fois j'ai appris quelque
chose dernièrement pis c'est un parfum
change tout moi je t'ai pas un gars qui
portaient les parfums je me suis fait
souvent dire maison worth alors une
petite touche j'ai commencé à mettre le
parfum rifan 2 mindscape ya comme des
petites touches d'agrumes jeu sans eux
je regarde d'arrêter de me sentir en
fils depuis j'ai eu que des commentaires
positifs fait que je vous entends déjà
dire j'aimerais se sentir comme ph
mais là vous avez une opportunité en or
fait le parfum est disponible chez
mindscape cc c'est mon coup de coeur une
sinon mon produit coûte car le chemin de
ce clip c'est leur nouveau produit pour
pour les poils de nez parce que depuis
qu'on a reçues bob le chef le podcast ci
qui distribue les polonais c'était
vraiment important
je suis vraiment servent qu'une chose
mais polonais puis j'avais cinq ans que
je les vois dépassé de montner trois
passes à beaupuy ça m'énerve mais avec
son bras sans aucun point qui dépense
des parts et les narines clean clean
clean comme on le remarque tout le monde
mais l'état dont 20 des belles narines
c'est incroyable non tous les produits
même équipe que vous connaissez déjà le
land moïse 3.0 pour crimes et ses bijoux
de famille comme on dit l'instrument
tentes et par excès c'est trop fort ça
va tellement bien mesquin on les adore
yes men un code promo pour vous autres
qui vous donne 20% le rabais plus la
livraison gratuite
on a changé les codes promo avec faîtes
attention c'est sans filtre 20 ans en un
mot en lettres majuscules 20 ans
chiffres pour 20% de rabais et le
shipping gratuit merci la gamme chez
mindscape wii est une production du
studio sfb bienvenue au sans fil le bois
de castres on parle de ce qu'on veut
nous inviter date si tu perds contre
avec moi dominick plante ou non complet
de mener qu que je l'écris plantes comme
on le pense
avec un aussi à être cette semaine on a
reçu robert paul juster qui a fait le
podcast un petit peu le partout la suite
du podcast avec ce nul bien où on a
parlé du stress prenant que ceux d'ici
là peut-être écouté puis s'il n'avait
pas écouté je vous recommande en fait
d'aller écouter le podcast avec son eu
les pieds parce qu'on a tout mis les
bases des connaissances puis des comment
le stress fonctionne pour ensuite avec
robert aller plus loin
alain peu plus
macro parler un peu plus de de
sociologie parler de comment le stress
avec certains groupes de la société plus
que d'autres allaient dans les termes un
petit peu plus technique que justement
c'était vraiment super passionnant
passionnant pas de casse ou lorsqu'on
plonge vraiment plus dans la science
directement dit sincèrement fascinant de
voir je pense qu'on a un aperçu de
violations s'est rendu à la fin nous
expliquer les prochaines études qui
allait faire ses étudiants le faire
c'est vraiment on sent qu'on est à la
fine pointe de la recherche sur ce
domaine là qui le stresse c'était
vraiment facile tout à fait puis après
chaque podcast peut-être que vous le
savez vous nous avez entendu en parler
on enregistre encore moins de filtres
doom nicole et moi sur notre page
piquionne donc on discute sur la
conversation convient d'avoir on
réfléchit un petit peu plus longuement
puis si vous voulez avoir accès à 6
comme gîte sera lancée exclusivement
pétrole dont vous pouvez vous abonner à
l'ap hp tron le lien va être dans la
description des podcasts commenté dans
la conversation partager à vos amis
propager inabo de la bonne nouvelle
carrément et surtout profité de cette
conversation là donc bonne écoute ses
principaux fonds du sport toute banale
bienvenue merci beaucoup c'est ça
parlement parfait bienvenu merci
beaucoup d'être lu on voulait faire une
partie d'eux un peu du parc à ce qu'on a
fait avec sonia parce que les gens n'ont
vraiment vraiment apprécié je pense que
nous aussi nous aussi puis puis sogno t
comme on disait tantôt est
extraordinaire vraiment puis le sujet
aussi touche tout le monde parce qu'en
fait tout le monde produit des hormones
de stress dans sa vie un moment donné
que fasciste en un sujet qui vraiment je
pense important à savoir comment geely
justement avec ses hormones de stress
l'appui comment percevoir le stress je
pense que si c'était une des choses qui
ressortait beaucoup du disco de sonia
c'est d'arrêter de voir le stress comme
quelque chose de négatif ont pu
d'apprendre à gérer parce qu'on réussira
jamais dans notre vie à ce coupé de
toute source de stress est impossible
même qui sait pas souhaitable je pense
le sait qui donc toi tu as été un
utilisant justement de sonia oui donc
j'ai passé dix ans avec sonia j'ai
commencé mon baccalauréat avec fait à
brochets juste lorsque john crowley je
l'aï approché le micro virtuel je lave
ou la dgi d'avoir un peu comme un
crapaud donc on n'a pas su poser le
commandant à l'usagé que j'ai commencé
comme bénévole au bac puis après j'ai
fait une maîtrise en neurosciences avec
elle puis après un doctorat pita
maîtrise apporte exactement sur quoi
donc au début c'était vraiment le stress
chronique et le vieillissement et après
ça c'était le stress chronique et
l'épuisement professionnel puis à
l'intérieur de soi je suis vraiment
intéressé à comprendre les différences
en femmes l'espérance de sex differences
de gens qui la question sur laquelle on
s'est un peu laissé avec avec sonia dans
le fond tu es à la fin de ce podcast on
est arrivé sur ce terrain là puis je dis
vous inviterez robert pourrait l'être
mais avant que t'es con qu'on saute à
pieds joints dans ce
ce sujet là comme on dit en octobre que
ça peut être intéressant de quelqu'un
qui avait pas écouter le podcast avec
sonia ou car besoin d'un rappel c'est
qu'on pourrait faire ainsi des taux des
notions clés mettons qu'on a déjà
mentionné l'ex au gnouf arrangeur des
résumés la pression pour être en
discussions sur des nouveaux territoires
et un génial donc juste pour commencer
sonia lupien est vraiment la reine du
stress au québec c'est moi qui marque
c'est elle qui m'a formé toute sa
carrière est vraiment didier à
comprendre comment les hormones de
stress donc le cortisol semaine et fâché
du monde des jeunes des plus vieux puis
le but finalement de toute cette
recherche et de comprendre les
différences individuelles dont qui est
le plus vulnérable à développer des
problèmes de stress et aussi qui est
plus résilient
donc n'importe qui qui va avoir une
réponse de stress donc combattre où
furent on va avoir une augmentation
d'hormones de stress pis essentiellement
le cortisol votre transformer le gras en
sucre pour donner notre corps l'énergie
pour être capable de combats toujours
intéressant il ya un concept théorique
qui dit que les femmes n'aura peut-être
pas nécessairement la réponse combattre
fuir ça serait plus une réponse de
protection et affiliation donc en
anglais de friends super intéressant que
avec l'évolution
la réponse de stress à serez peut-être
différent en islam et les femmes qui met
donc le stress
essentiellement c'est l'énergie
finalement exactement ça c'est l'énergie
qui quittent finalement qui transforme
et qui comme eux plus sécrétée dans le
cas piqué qui doit être canalisée
finalement exactement puis comme sonia
disait on à absents besoin d'arrêter de
parler de stress comme quelque chose de
mauvais parce que c'est ça ça vraiment
permis notre espèce d'abord de continuer
à contribuer le aujourd'hui c'était très
exactement exactement donc son issue on
va dire que n'importe qui vous est si
vous avez une situation qui
un sans faute à un manque de contrôle
ces nouvelles c'est l'imprévisible si la
menace à votre égo vous allez avoir une
réponse de senez biologique donc les 4
ceci sentiment sentiment perte de
contrôle
nouveauté imprévisibilité puis menacé
les groupes exactement moi je pense le
dénominateur commun avec tout ça c'est
le contre au hockey tsonga pense que tu
dois être c'est le sens ce que le
matelas personnes étaient menacées c'est
pas exactement de contrôle
mais si quelqu'un met en question la
capacité de bien performer
c'est que tu as perdu un peu le contrôle
de ton image du monde exactement mais
qu'est ce que j'aime beaucoup de la
recette de son mieux c'est que ça aide a
vraiment cassé un peu qu'ils plus
sensibles à certains ingrédients non moi
par exemple la nouveauté
je déteste donc c'est quelque chose que
je sache enfin j'essaie de me
contextualiser avec nouvel environnement
pour me déstresser
est-ce que c'est saulnier qui est arrivé
avec ses 4 ou si quelque chose qui est
dans la communauté scientifique y est
depuis longtemps un chablis c'est sonia
qu'il a vraiment mis en place comme
outil pour le grand public
les recherches de john médecine qui elle
a parlé c'est un psychologue qui
s'intéressent à comprendre c'est quoi
les facteurs psychologiques qui va
réduire un stress biologique chez le
monde donc lui s'intéressait aux
parachutistes donc ce qu'il fallait pour
la première - versus les vétérans dont
qui exposait le monde à des situations
toujours différents donc on s'entend que
le vétéran la peau la même réponse de
stress car nous dit donc lui c'est
vraiment intéressés de comprendre c'est
quoi les facteurs puis cécile vraiment
le contrôle qui lui a concentré dessus
il ya d'autres cherchent par des
chercheurs pour le nom de christine
camani qui ont fait une revue la
littérature pour comprendre un peu c'est
quoi les ingrédients qui vont se dresser
le monde qu'on les amène en laboratoire
on peut pas dire qu'est ce qu'on fait
dans l'abattoir parce que sinon le monde
arrivés moins stressés exact mais
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont conclus qui sait
que sochaux d'ayew le souhaite donc la
menace sociaux évaluatif faire en sorte
qu'on va avoir une réponse de stress
d'un laboratoire donc sonné a appris
cette information la piraterie coûte
les priorités c'est la nouveauté c'est
le manque de contrôle c'est la menace à
l'ego puis elle est vraiment ressorti
cette cette belle recette pour la pour
le grand public mais est ce qui m'est
ont trié sonia disait mais témoin au
défi si d'en trouver un cinquième vous
arriverez porter vraiment réel danger
physique ça se sait pas ce ne serait pas
une team et on l'autre jour je faisais
québec montréal ça sur l'a20 à en pleine
tempête de neige il c'est partout et des
shorts des deux bords de la ruche
déstressant maudite et est ce que ce cas
c'est vrai est ce que ça sera ça serait
pas une source de stress de dj danger
poindre
je pense ça c'est plus la peur et puis
si jamais vous voulez d'autres personnes
qui ressort du bassin de riches de sonia
c'est marie-france marin mais quelques
uns de mes collègues on était en même
cohorte avec son chien
puis elle s'intéresse vraiment à
décortiquer la différence entre la peur
et le stress qui a l'air actuellement
des études où elle regardait des parents
qui ont été exposés à un trauma pour
voir à quel point les enfants puis les
adolescents développe des
conditionnements vis-à-vis leur part
donc je dirais que ta réponse de stress
que tu as us oui c'est naturellement une
réponse de stress c'est vraiment une
réponse de par sa griffe super vite
ça arrivait dans l'espace d'une coupe de
seconde il faut qu on est serein donc
c'est tout
axa s'est vraiment plus l'adrénaline
planeur à danané donc sonné avait
mentionné sa le sentiment que tu vas
mourir c'est long plus c'est cela la kz2
stress puis tout pays cortisol va venir
apprendre plus plusieurs minutes pour
continuer la réponse était stressé tout
le long mais j'imagine que c'est aussi
j'imagine que les facteurs imprévisibles
la perte de contrôle ou si un 5e de la
glace qui est exact c'est littéralement
tués quand un ch reprend clos c'est
littéralement une des pertes de contrôle
littéralement perte de contrôle
ouais mais c'est l'apport puis le stress
est très semblable et cousines
oui puis c'est beaucoup de neurobiologie
semblables mais c'est quand même des
axes un peu de ça puis tout qui a
vraiment un stress physique
c'est comme ça qu'on a vraiment connu le
concept du stress donc plus de
l'histoire c'est un chercheur par le nom
de hans est lié au non-versement réalité
à méguet l'avant mais ont oublié ça lui
s'intéressait vraiment exposés tous des
rades et déstressant il ya commencé sa
carrière vraiment avec plus d hormones
sexuelles puis avait un genre de
cocktail qui voulaient regarder en lien
avec je pense était le vieillissement
puis c'était un homme brillant super
productif je pense été nominé pour nos
belges pensent jamais qu'un étudiant un
cocktail de coach pas c'était comme un
genre de molécules avait rien je
considère comme une version d'estrogènes
puisse intéresser à un niveau
pharmacologique de comprendre si ça va
des effets sur ces erreurs n'étaient pas
très bons avec ses bras il échappait
puis avec le temps les recommencer à
développer des conditions le plus besoin
pis avec cette recherche qui a vraiment
créé le terme stress en biologie pour
parler de vraiment comment n'importe
quel stresseurs physique donc spécifique
aurez une réponse qui appelait le genoa
dati shenzhen donc le corps au début
avoir une augmentation d'hormones de
stress puis avec le temps il va avoir
une fatigue qui se passe donc toute sa
carrière était dédiée
vraiment comprendre comment le stress
physique aurait un effet sur les
hormones de stress puisque john médecine
qui a pris sens puisque le j ai dit
écoute je crois pas qu'ils c'est juste
n'importe quelle situation qui va
stresser le monde
il doit avoir des facteurs
psychologiques non physique qui peut
amener un réponse des spis et c'est là
que tout la domaine dans lequel sont
elles qui m'ont appuyé marie france fait
partie c'est une c'est super intéressant
et je veux je veux qu'on revienne un
petit peu sur quelque chose que tu
disais plus tôt
tu disais que je travaillais sur ça fait
deux fois que tu mentionnes disait qu'il
travaillait sur le stress par rapport au
vieillissement moi c'est quelque chose
qui m'intéresse beaucoup
vieillissement j'en ai déjà parlé dans
d'autres cas ce clm et le stress
chronique j'imagine a des effets sur le
vieillissement
absolument peux tu nous parler plus rien
de son sillage je retourne encore et à
sonia parce que c'est quand j'ai dit
c'est vraiment la reine du stress à son
union à travailler avec un chercheur a
pendant son post doc bruce matthews and
the queen c'est vraiment le grand père
julian s'allier puis il ya but you want
you think you sell disent que c'est
l'arrière grappin aussi de grappa c'est
le grand-père et papil c'est vraiment
comme le fondateur de la maison stress
inquiet pied bus mcqueen était à
l'université que féru malheureusement il
est décédé au début de l'année passée
c'est une grande perte pour la séance
bruce a formé presque été actif jusqu'à
ajouter à la fin mai jusqu'à la magie
continue est encore pertinent
oui absolument qui coûte je pense les
beaucoup de chercheurs dans leur labo
c'est l'oeuvre de leur ville et on est
passionné de ces il ya pas de retraite
qui existent qu'est ce qu'on va faire m
donc plus le clou d'informer tous les
grands scientifiques de stress donc ils
sont nés lupien macro demies nikki un
grand chercheur à montréal s'ouvre
légers puis génétique
il ya plein d'autres chercheurs que je
remercie pour ce qui est super bon vu
que les orateurs de tout qui stresse et
science qu'est ce que son union à fait
avec blue c'est qu'elle a pris toutes
les connaissances de stress chez les
rats et les appliquer chez les humains
qui est un délai plus grandes
découvertes qu'elle a fait au début de
sa carrière
cette claquette été capable de démontrer
que des noms des vieux qui ont une
augmentation d'hormones de stress donc à
courtisols pendant une période de temps
on diminue à son d'une volutes d'une
volumes d'ipo camping dont leur cerveau
de 14%
l'hippocampe une région du cerveau très
important pour la mémoire la cnhi sont
là que la contextualisations d'une
situation
c'est la première région qui affecté par
les romains n'ont de la relation que le
stress puis à la démence et était
vraiment sortis de cette relation là est
ressorti de quelle façon c'était quoi le
constat donc j'imagine qu'ils étaient
bambi dans la forêt puis ils se
rencontrent un ours a besoin d'avoir une
réponse de stress mais il faut aussi se
souvenir ou sur où se trouve dans la
forêt donc cette région du cerveau
l'hippocampe est impliqué dans toute
cette contenu externalisation mais aussi
avec la régulation du stress donc qu'on
a une réponse de stress puis le cortisol
circulent un peu partout dans notre sens
ça retourne au cerveau puis ça ça va
actu et ça va interagir avec des
récepteurs dans l'hippocampe puis le
clip au combat actuellement fermé la kz2
stress donc si tu es quelqu'un qui a été
stressé chroniquement puis ton
hippocampe devient plus petit des
capacités de fernie temps les réponses
des stress va être affecté a piqué ce
qui est super intéressant c'est que
l'hippocampe sont ils faisaient partie
du réseau qui s'appelait à l'époque un
pour ma fille à ce que c'était la région
dans le monde dans lequel le monde s'est
concentré le plus dans la domaine stress
parce que c'est une région vraiment dans
le centre du cerveau assez facile à
caractériser pour l'imagerie cérébrale a
mis à d'autres régions dont qui est
l'ami dalkeith paraît important est le
cortex préfrontal donc où j'allais avec
tout ça m'étonnerait de longévité aussi
pu commencer doucement donc cette
découverte que tsonga a fait écoute ça
st
grande découverte pour les domaines qui
il ya beaucoup de monde qui s'intéresse
à la relation entre le stress et la
démence mais c'est vraiment compliqué
parce que dans certaines conditions
reliées à la démence souvent on va voir
les niveaux de cortisol qui sont très
très élevé mais il ya d'autres
conditions c'est très très bas donc
c'est très difficile à comprendre c'est
quoi l'intérêt action c'est quoi la
mélange de biomarqueurs qui va faire en
sorte que quelqu'un va avoir des
troubles cognitifs mais qui va devenir
alzheimer donc c'est le cortisol est
vraiment qu'est ce qui est vraiment
important tout ça c'est que les ondes et
stress c'est vraiment la première partie
d'une réponse de stress mais avec le
temps on va avoir un effet domino sur
plein d'autres bien au menu donc le
cortisol va avoir un effet sur le
système immunitaire
le système minutes avant d'avoir un
effet sur nos cholestérol le cortisol
est produit avec le cholestérol donc on
va chercher la nourriture pour augmenter
le niveau de cholestérol
ça ça va augmenter notre football ça va
augmenter notre pression artérielle ça
on doit mettre du gros donc il ya toute
cette constellation de changement puisse
faire un niveau biologique puis ça c'est
qu'est-ce que j'ai commencé ma carrière
avec avec son lien de regarder tout ce
réseau de biomarqueurs qui devient dés
réguliers avec le temps puisque c'est
ici tous les points finaux mais c'est
des points si des effets sur la santé
qui sont négatifs a fait puis dans
perspective parce que soigner dix fois
rire de voir le stress comme comme
quelque chose de négatif comme encore
accordent ces deux choses la fête en
fait j'imagine que comme on dit plutôt
le stress une fonction ça c'est sûr puis
c'est quoi ces effets positifs puis
comment qu'on évite ces effets négatifs
que les matons pied être qu'après son
pour retourner dans le plus technique
mais tim est temps pour les gens qui
nous écoutent qui ont besoin de trucs le
sur comment justement éviter toutes
sortes d'effets négatifs sur la santé
c'est que les trucs qu'on peut donner le
ton écoute si je connaissais la raison
de la réponse à ce show familial 1 je
pense l'essentiel c'est vraiment de
trouver une façon de poney saman relaxé
mais d'être capable de fermer la réponse
de stress donc si on est quelqu'un par
exemple qui à la tendance d'être stressé
et puis de ruminer
avec la rumination qu'on va commencer à
boire plus où on vraiment j'ai mal
qu'est ce qui va arriver on sait que
notre réponse de stress va continuer
donc de trouver des manières de fermer
la kz2 stress l'essentiel
puis chaque personne va avoir une façon
différente de le faire donc sonia elle
parle souvent de prendre une marche avec
ce fait d'une heure c'est sa façon de
gérer son stress pour moi c'est souvent
ce type de boire de l'alcool je cède pas
face à léo jim mois et coûte quand je
suis sur une machine
j'appelle ça mon mp adaptec parce que je
dois je pense à tous les affaires gym
stress puis que je suis un collapsus
camji votre célibat
des fois le monde vient taper jay roach
pour moi c'est pour moi c'était vraiment
le cardio que j'aimerais faire je
m'étais ouvert je pense n'importe quelle
situation n'importe quelle activité
qu'on fait qui nous fait oublier un peu
notre stresseurs ça va aider à diminuer
la réponse de stress pipe juste pour
retourner au fait de stress une bonne
chose
j'ai introduit un concept qui s'appelle
la lost asie donc l'homéostasie c'est un
concept très classique en biologie donc
notre sans jamais dépasser un certain
niveau de toxicité hassidique une
température de corps va toujours rester
dans nombre c'est tous des paramètres un
peu à bazas qui sont régulés tous les
lots maîtriser les flux de régulation de
toutes ces paramètres le du corps exact
on imagine un reptile qui est un peu
froid doit commencer à aller dans une
place où il va avoir le plus chaud pour
être directement dans le soleil donc
c'est un exemple de comment un reptile
change son comportement pour red hat et
son sa physiologie interne donc pierre
kary par contre avec des situations où
on est stressé c'est que on a besoin
d'adapter à l'avion en l'environnement
puissent aussi un exemple de lalobbe
stasi donc la lonase hisser comment
notre corps va changer la physiologie un
temps pour s'adapter à l'environnement
dans la réponse à ces la mer exemple
puis la personne qui a créé sa c2
généraux biologiste qu'un des pieds
d'humoriste
ceux qui ont regardé la pression rtl
donc tout le fonctionnement du système
cardiovasculaire et on dit que ça
n'existe pas vraiment bbc chromeo
statique de de la fraîcheur parce que ça
va toujours changer telle notre pression
va être plus haut pendant le sexe que
pendant le sommet quand on est stressé
ça va changer aussi ça va changer aussi
avec l'âge ça va changer en fonction de
ce statut socioéconomique la race
donc oui on dit que c'est ce concept au
mieux aux états y est un peu plat tu as
a pas de rapport donc le concept dalo
stasi été introduits pour parler
vraiment de tout les systèmes
biologiques et mécanismes biologiques ou
on change notre fonctionnement est temps
pour s'adapter alors devant une équipe
qui sont pas stables qui vont qui vont
beaucoup moduler la même journée par
exemple exactement puis la réponse de
stress sa mère exemple il ya d'autres
chercheurs que ça intéresse beaucoup de
regarder glucose à lost est ici sous la
halle a aussi saisi dans le concept de
toxicomanie comment tous des paramètres
va changer mais qu'est-ce qui est
pourtant tout ça c'est que n'importe
quel changement qu'on va voir
dans une réponse de stress avec les
hormones de stress va avoir un effet sur
plein d'autres systèmes
puis c'est avec le temps que leslie
mécanisme à lost asie comme une réponse
de stress va user un peu le
fonctionnement du coeur et du cerveau
puis ça ça vieillit essentiellement
toutes les apps ratissent le mécanisme
de notre réponse de stress puis ça avec
le temps devient quelque chose qu'on
appelle à charge allostatique donc à
l'ostal icloud en anglais puis c'est
essentiellement le lower inter du stress
chronique une en synergie avec des
mauvais comportements de santé donc
quand on est plus stressé on à la
tendance de moins manger bien plus fumer
plus mon ex est donc tout à fait ton
toute autre méthode anti stress et de
boire de l'alcool épaulé par commande
attend que c'est vraiment dit ben écoute
pour moi ça marche quelque chose de
drôle tout acquéreur est vraiment
concentré sur se charge allostatique
joint en parler un peu plus
après puis beaucoup de monde s'intéresse
à voir c'est quoi les comportements de
santé qui peut être liée à une charge
allostatique puis sambre est il que
l'alcool n'est pas un facteur qui
contribue à la charge allostatique même
que celle inverse donc le monde qui boit
un peu plus un chercheur ou satie plus
bas il ne comprend pas exactement
pourquoi je pense l'alcool il ya un
aspect social - puis donc je pense qu'on
pense au stress et la résilience
on parle vraiment un mélange de facteurs
de risque puis de facteurs de protection
aucun exemple si j'étais quelqu'un
vraiment stressé tu vois un crise a mis
ses drapeaux ces temps ci mais si tu
veux dire le monde normal imagine studio
qu'est baby viennois robert tu vas
parler de monstres et sors tu vas boire
mais tu as aussi ce soutien social donc
tu as comme un facteur de lys l'alcool
mélangé avec un facteur de protection
donc je pense pour comprendre le stress
chronique un niveau individuel faut
vraiment prendre en compte ce mélange de
facteurs de risques et facteurs de
pruneaux mission de quelqu'un qui boit
plus est le plus de chances d'avoir une
vie sociale plus épanouie mettons exact
quelque chose aussi que j'ai réfléchi
beaucoup achètent aussi à quelqu'un qui
regarde ça mais comparé à une
consommation d'alcool et à une grande
différence en termes de statut
socio-économique entre un shot d'une
bière puis une bouteille de verre de vin
rouge 5 en dehors donc je pensais aussi
c'est quelque chose à considérer -
proment que la personne a que les
bouteilles de vin rouge 1,50 dollar au
moins d'éléments stressant dans sa vie
que la personne qui arriva à peine avec
sa soupe au 10 avril plus de la série
qui se voit la bière de microbrasserie
matin c'est quelqu'un on parle de stress
chronique est petit le définir donc ça
c'est super bonne question donc c'est
pas facile à savoir c'est quoi
parce que tout le monde mais dont je
souffre beaucoup pour raconter la
question plate avec un meilleur angle
tout le monde est capable de savoir au
kilo
j'ai des papillons dans le vent en ce
moment je suis stressé ceci du stress on
reconnaît ce team et j'imagine que le
stress chronique qui est sur des plus
longues périodes de temps est souvent
plus difficile à saisir
difficile à comprendre mais je pense qu
est-ce qui est qui se passe avec le
vraiment un stress chronique c'est que
on va commencer à voir vraiment un
changement sur nos comportements de
santé
donc si on commence à voir c'est un
manque de sommeil ou comment savoir plus
où on commence à manger mal c'est une
bonne indication au niveau
comportemental qu'il ya quelque chose
qui se passe maintenant quand ça sera un
niveau vraiment physique on commence à
avoir des symptômes reliés au stress
puis ça peut être n'importe quoi ça peut
être des problèmes de peau ça peut être
un système immunitaire affaibli
ça peut être la pression artérielle
augmenter et aussi tout psychologique
donc si on commence à trouver qu'on
n'est pas capable de fonctionner dans la
même manière qu'auparavant
c'est une très bonne éducation on est
dans un stress chronique qui compense à
la santé mentale tous les to les la
majorité de conditions psychologiques
psychiatriques
l'un des critères essentiels pour être
considéré comme une maladie
si avoir un fonctionnement diminué et
est capable de fonctionner sans que l'on
faisait auparavant puis ccc encore
encore une fois pour reprendre l'idée
que quand il ya un stress directes
immédiates est capable de trouver la
source rapidement mais quand tu
commences à remarquer tous ces
changements locke de noter que ce soit
physique ce soit comportementale que ce
soit psychologique pour réaliser que
tinqueux tête en période de stress
chronique j'imagine comment est-ce qu'on
n'est capable de trouver le
le réseau la raison en fait la cause des
registres est généralement si je mets
juste une cause contrat porte d'une
situation traumatique
c'est généralement une accumulation puis
je pense la cabine est tellement un
exemple - une accusation de stresseurs
puis de la natation puis de ma
l'adaptation
tiens on en est cette pandémie qui a
commencé au début c'était tellement
stressant je me souviens on était pas
sûr au début qui est ce qui se passait
je me souviens je faisais le magasinage
pour l'épicerie de maman puis j'arrive
et je tenais les sacs poubelle je te
vois plutôt maintenance et on sait qu'un
peu plus haut comment ça ça fonctionne
mais saches complètement changé notre
mode de vie ce moi personnellement je
trouve que j'ai trop meeting par zoom
j'ai trop du maire il ya trop de cons
qu'on veut avoir ce contact social mais
ça fond ça qu'il ya comme une
accumulation de stresseurs qui se passe
puis je pense pour pour vraiment être
dans une situation de savoir c'est quoi
la source de notre stress vous faut
vraiment prendre un timeout pid vraiment
évaluer quelles sont les choses qui me
permet de bien réussir mais mes tâches
puis qu'est qu'est ce qui les empêche
pour moi personnellement c'est
l'immerger besoins trouver les
meilleures stratégies pour gérer ça
c'est sûr que je peux être plus
discipliné mais ça reste quand même que
l'on vit dans une époque où on est on
est conditionné des trains plus
responsable
donc peut-être - twitter à facebook et
intégrale c'est tout table ou plus si tu
reçois sont ni on est toujours un peu
dans cette mode à moins que tu
synchronise pas ton seul l'or avec avec
tes bottes à courriels sur se découvrir
le travail jetons cellulaire qu'en 48
heures le soir
en effet que ça arrête jamais s'arrête
jamais mais c'est pour d'autres mondes
je pense mal particulièrement au monde
qui n'ont pas les ressources économiques
pendant la pandémie cesser complètement
les stresseurs différents puis ça reste
toujours que si on a un manque de
contrôle dans nos vies qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire pour récurer avoir ce sens
sensation de contrôler c'est pas évident
pour tout le monde non je pense
malheureusement la pandémie a vraiment
démontré à quel point on a des égalités
pas seulement au niveau économique mais
d égalité de genre de race ethnicité
donc ce point tu peux pas vraiment
répondre complètement parce que je pense
l'essentiel c'est de vraiment faire
d'être spéciaux de comprendre quelle est
la source de nos stresseurs mais aussi
d'avoir un peu de compassion
particulièrement dans la situation
actuelle on va pas être parfait on va
faire plein d'erreurs on va voir trop où
on va manger mal d'être capable de se
dire ok ça va donner un exemple la
semaine passée
c'est là c'était le vendredi soir
j'étais chez ma mère c'était la première
la fin de la première semaine de travail
je me suis dit ça va faire du bien puis
je ne souhaitais pas capable après mais
vraiment pas non mais tu y es ce que tu
dis ce n'est parlé de carrément le
mettre sur papier le trick en gamme
étant justement tu es là ton l'inpi de
progrès de remise de l'amst qui tourne
c'est peut-être rumination de ces seuls
mots rumination va cesser de tourner
toujours les mêmes ennuis même passer
dans la tête des vrais mans fall
exercice des maths sur papier tue d
écrire puis l'a précédée d construire
avec les 4 je ne commenterai pas le seul
facteur de stress
puis j'ai juste l'action de faire ce jeu
imagine votre donner un peu plus de
sentiment de contrôle sur ta situation
pivot pro mente aider aussi à déléguer
cette partie de ton cerveau sur la fuite
après ceux de moins de moins penser
exactement puis ça ça vient
il ya vraiment des stratégies date at
d'adaptation dont on en est à 10
cropping sur hal gill qui sont plus
positives que d'autres donc l'évitement
bling sauf donc dire grâce et toute ma
faute
oui je peaufine king qui tout à la ponte
vive magiquement ça va bien aller
ça vaut bien oui ça peut fonctionner
comme stratégie d'adaptation mais c'est
pas fantastique durable ou sinon ça va
devenir enfin en cinq ans
ceux qui sont plus positif c'est de
chercher de soutien social et qu'elles
sont appelées aurait provoqué scoping
chez plein de sang français mais l'astre
la datation des légumes à la source est
classique et en allemand kik stress de 6
qui stresse je vais donner l'exemple
avec sonia de 6,6 qui était pas étudié
ton examen le fait d'étudier risque de
tête de stress inzaghi woman show
exactement puis je pense n'importe
quelle situation ou même si on peut pas
changer le résultat directement de
dépenser et puis pensez à plusieurs
stratégies c'est l'essentiel manches et
j'ai un grand joueur d'échecs puis je
pense au toujours penser à la variation
qui pensait à la stratégie puis je monte
positionne tonton je puis je pense
n'importe quel stress à mon avis fois
capable de vraiment mastiquer puis
ruminer toutes les possibilités pour
certaines personnes
j'ai le monde un peu plus dépressif et
ou si le monde a plus plus anxieux ça
peut être et décide de faire ses
exercices de de masturbation
si la kfor mais je pense en général
c'est très bonne façon de reprendre un
peu le contrôle la situation tend tout
en touche découpé pour faire une joke
leucate parler des facteurs de risque ou
entre des corrélations entre des
personnes en stress chronique puis des
comportements comme toxicomanie
alcoolisme
ce que j'imagine que vous voulez mesurer
ce cas pas de mesurer le stress
justement dans les dents des prises de
sang dans notre livre ce j'imagine que
vous voyez justement création de
certains comportements mais est ce qu
est l inverse
pipita canado puis est ce qu à l inverse
il ya certains types de comportements
que tu décris mettons une personne
sportive peut-être en moyenne développe
moins de stress chronique whisky est ce
que le poussif et ce qu est ce que tu es
capable d'aider certains très positif de
comportement qui fait en sorte qu'ils
sont peut-être mon développer un stress
chronique
c'est une super bonne question qui ça
revient plus haut point que je disais de
le mélange est facteur de décès d'un
mélange de facteurs de protection donc
l'exercice
et c'est je pense un lien entre vous qui
est un athlète les deux pendant plus lui
mais les deux peut-il être d'être
physiquement actif c'est sûr c'est bon
pour la santé mais ça peut aller à
l'extrême où ça peut avoir un effet sur
notre corps puis usées puisse dresser un
point extrêmement donc je pense
n'importe quels comportements de santé
même le sommet si on dort trop c'est
quand même être aussi pire que peut pas
dormir est censé tout est un peu un
balance mais j'imagine qu'ils aient plus
de monde qui souffrent de faire passer
le sport de penser dormait risques de
troubles pour s'offrir faire trop de
porc faussement vraiment si je pense à
l'ailé jeunesse gymnastes très jeunes
souvent s'il ya des problèmes
d'alimentation
c'est vraiment un extrait en général
c'est une super qu'elles sont parce que
je pense qu'il ya certains sous groupes
qui vont en voir un mélange de facteurs
de risques et facteurs de protection
dont je vais donner un exemple la
crainte est gay sécurité qui a beaucoup
plus de stigma beaucoup plus de
discrimination mais c'est aussi un clint
qui s'entraîne un peu plus ce qui
généralement faire un peu plus attention
à la diète qui est un peu plus ou si
elle ya plus de problèmes d'alimentation
donc ce groupe c'est un groupe qui a ces
fuites physiques physiologiques mans
donc moi quand je les regarde dans mes
études de stress y aura clairement un
fonctionnement physiologique est plus
saine que les hommes hétérosexuels
donc quand son groupe même s'ils sont
ils
en face à reims tig mans comme sous
groupes futur sc socioculturel pour et
n'importe quelle raison ils ont un corps
généralement un peu plus vite que les
eaux qui fait en sorte que certains
paramètres liés au stress va pas être la
même que qu'est ce qu'on voit dans
d'autres groupes mais qu'ils disent pas
intéressant excuser ce que je peux dire
après une mécanique v6 pas intéressant
parce qu'ils essaient dit je te mentir
le fait qu'ils aient cette politique et
cette pression là mais lorsque le fait
que ce groupe le fasse plus d'exercices
fassent plus attention si ce pas positif
mais qu dans certains cas extrêmes si
c'est comme il ya du positif et du
négatif mais je donne et un autre petit
cours d'histoire pendant la crise de
sida et de vie h il y avait tout un
mouvement de chez les anguilles les abus
sexuels de vraiment s'entraîner pour
avoir la musculation pour montrer qu'il
n'avait pas l'infection qui n'était pas
infecté donc un niveau culturel c'est ça
ça fait en sorte qu'il ya eu comme un
morceau kring culture mais quitter pour
contrebalancer évidemment une épidémie
dans la communauté puis combattre un
préjugé justement très exactement puis
ça c'est vraiment intéressant parce que
ça revient encore à quai ce que je
disais d' de la combinaison de facteurs
de risque la commission de facteurs de
protection
si gm est juste un ou l'autre voici faut
faire l'exercice une heure par jour ça
va tout dépendre de les sources de
stress dans notre environnement
puis je l'entendais en entrevue
autrefois l'un l'autre fois hier en
préparant pour aujourd'hui le whisky tu
parlais des communautés lgbt plus puis
pour juste pour rebondir sur ce qu'on se
convient de mentionner le fait que la
plupart des hommes homosexuels étaient
plus vite que les hommes hétérosexuels
puis j'imagine qu'à l'intérieur du
groupe hommes homosexuels
il ya eu plusieurs autres facteurs de
stress mais tu disais dans l'entrevue
j'ai entendu que 1 des grandes
différences différenciateur c'était
le coming out cette fois que le comédien
avant le coming out et après le communal
puis admettons qu'on se penche un petit
peu là tu pourras peut-être qu'on
parlera plus de ceux un peu plus tard
aujourd'hui le mais les hommes
homosexuels après le coming out versus
en mode hétérosexuels qu'elles semblent
être les corrélations les différences
entre ces groupes là au niveau du stress
puis des facteurs de stress donc celle
acquittée à gvt cru plus le processus de
due qu'au meilleur c'est souvent très
très long ça donc en général n'importe
qui qui a des fantasmes sexuels pour le
même sexe ça va avoir un espace de 5 ans
ou la personne vais y réfléchir même à
vendre alors l'acte donc il ya toute
cette période de temps où la personne
pour être en détresse
puis après c'est sûr ça c'est pas
nécessairement de pau vouloir sortir du
placard si du questionnement exhale un
punch exactement moi je suis un homme
gay puis j'ai su quand j'avais 10 ans
que j'étais gay mon père était un peu
hyper masculin non plus caché ça c'était
l'âge de 10 ans à 14 ans et c'était
difficile j'ai eu beaucoup de problèmes
de santé mentale mais je pense que ce
processus a fait en sorte que j'ai
soumis à un stress heures que la
majorité de monde n'ont pas fait face
donc ça m'a aidé à développer un peu de
résilience
mon premier n'était pas super facile
mais là aussi ça a pris du temps
donc je pense à beaucoup de monde qui
ont fait ce parcours
ça fait en sorte qu'ils ont un stress et
unique qui est spécifique à leur
identité pour le montrant jean reno
mineurs saisissement deux fois caméra
donc la meilleure pour leur orientation
sexuelle puis des fois aussi pour
l'argent
exactement appui pour la communauté lgbt
que plus un des plus grands stresseurs
c1 d'accepter que tu es tu es une
minorité sexuelle ou de genre et de
faire leur coming out
donc je pense qu est ce qui se passe
avec le monde qui ont ce processus
s'adapte ça aide à développer un peu de
lésiner ans
puis je pense et ça en effet que je suis
en train de voir avec leurs recherches
que j'ai fait pendant mon doctorat avec
sonia donc je me suis là
la journée où son homme a accepté de
prendre dans son labo j'avais parlé avec
un de ces d'une de ses collègues comment
je voulais faire une étude de stresser
ligue et pouvoir capturer leur
réactivité
ça c'est un bon pitch de projet juste
jamais rentrer dans votre labo pour
stresser les gays essentiellement
s'appuie son n'aura pas accepté au début
a dit écoute en bon petit gars on va
commencer ça tranquillement donc
s'établissement épuisement professionnel
qui un jour elle m'a dit coach brown
j'ai plein décidant cet été j'ai pas
qu'on va faire faut pas tomber on tout
petit ce gai écoute ça ouvert tout une
porte de recherche parce qu'à l'époque
tout qui était en mode de stress
biologie du stress dans le milieu de
tout quitter agilité qq plus étaient
tous dans le contexte du vih ps2 puis je
voulais éviter ça ou l'autre ou si
c'était pour tout une domaines de
recherche qui essaie de comprendre
pourquoi le monde était gay ou pourquoi
le monde est étrange an pendant les
années 80 puis ça aussi ça m'intéressait
un peu moins parce que ça qu'est ce que
ça aurait pour la qualité le savoir
exactement parce que s'ils ont su si on
sait que c'est purement biologique ou
c'est purement l'environnement qu'est ce
que ça va faire pour nous donc tout ça
pour dire que je me suis intéressé à
cette question puis on a fait une étude
où on est stressé lacunes tgb puis on a
trouvé que en général qu on stresse le
monde en laboratoire les hommes
réagissent plus fort en termes de
production de cortisol donc tout le
monde si on est pour être stressé là et
maintenant si on prend un échantillon de
salive ça va prendre environ 20 minutes
pouvoir leur pic sans corde seul puis
nous qu'est ce qu'on fait en laboratoire
c'est que on amène le monde on n'est
fait qu'à demi
on prend des échantillons de salive
avant le stress heures puis après le
stress ans puis nous notre but c'est de
voir à quel point ils réagissent puis à
quel point sont capables de se calmer le
pompon une fois que le stress aurait pu
là dont on parle de lui activity
pierrick auvray je me suis intéressé de
voir qu'est ce que ça serait celle
acquittée lgb malheureusement on n'a pas
inclus deux parties entrent en jean mais
ça c'est à venir nous sommes bien à
appliquer ce qu'on a trouvé c'est que
les hommes gais bisexuels c'était
principalement dézinguer réel manque de
réponses en termes de cortisol
comparativement aux hommes hétérosexuels
un manque de réponse exacte comme
flatline ça c'est souvent quelque chose
qu'on voit dans la littérature sur le
trauma puis à l'épuisement professionnel
qu'il ya comme une mode de réponse parce
que quand les le corps était peu bête
quand le corps est il trop habitués au
stress en fait qu'est-ce que je pense
avec tout ça c'est que si on était en
situation de stress chronique
éventuellement le cerveau va dire écoute
faut qu'on arrête cette réponse donc il
va avoir un dialogue origine de tout le
fonctionnement du corps de sol mais ça
va faire qu'un autre symbole
contrebalancer donc qu'est ce que j'ai
trouvé c'est un exemple les hommes gays
dans mon échantillon avait le manque de
réponses comparativement aux hommes
hétéros qui avait la réponse qu'on voit
tout le temps dans ses études
mais quand on a fait une autre étude
pour garder le poupon la pression
artérielle
les hommes gais bisexuels était plus
élevé que les hommes étaient autant il
savait des niveaux bas de cortisone mais
des niveaux élevés de poule puis les
hommes hétérosexuels et corcelles et
lévis mais le pouls plus bas donc
mettons l'analyse de sa pipe les corrige
mois ci si ma lecture est mauvaise mais
c'est que le
le cortisol by la réaction au stress
permettrait de calmer certains autres
facteurs
comment on l'a l'année je m'explique je
pensais plus que quand un système a
commencé à diminuer son fonctionnement
un autiste en vo contrebalancer qui
n'est pas toujours une bonne chose donc
on parle souvent de discrimination puis
maladies cardiovasculaires mais je vais
aller plus loin parce que c'est juste un
résultat avec cet échantillon vous les
femmes - qu'est-ce qu'on a trouvé
c'était que des femmes lesbiennes et
bisexuels piste et principalement des
femmes bisexuelles
il répondait plus comme un homme
hétérosexuel donc ruiz avait un pic de
cortisol 40 minutes après le stress
heures qui a plus tard
donc on soupçonne que c'est peut-être un
peu de riz nation qui qui se passe donc
une fois que les stresseurs est plus là
c'était en train de ruminer puis la
chute j'étais pas très bon on apprend
dans cette tâche
j'ai mal fait ça c'est un exemple de
rémunération qui va faire en sorte que
la réponse de stress va continuer les
femmes hétérosexuelles il y avait un
manque de réponse donc si on comparait
les femmes hétérosexuelles puis les
hommes gais bisexuels c'était la même
genre de réponse donc le flatline puis
pour les femmes lesbiennes bisexuels
c'était plus comme une réponse d'hommes
étaient au sexuelle qu'est ce qui est
vraiment intéressant c'est qu'on a aussi
regardé les hormones sexuelles donc
l'estrogène progestérone et testostérone
puis qu'est-ce qu'on a trouvé c'est que
les femmes lesbiennes bisexuels avaient
des niveaux de testostérone plus les bep
puis il avait aussi la progestérone plus
olivier ça c'est vraiment intéressant
parce que cette augmentation de
d'hormones sexuelles était relié à un
cortisol plus élevé puis ça c'est
quelque chose vraiment intéressant parce
qu'il ya pendant une période de temps
dans les années 80 beaucoup de monde
s'intéressait à voir c'est quoi le
profil biologique pourrait expliquer
pourquoi quelqu'un est gay ou lesbienne
puis c'était un peu des banques et parce
que c'était pas y avait trop de
variabilité des fois c'est un niveau
trop élevé trop bas mais en général que
ce qui a été trouvé pour un tiers des
études c'était pour les femmes
lesbiennes et bisexuels
y'avait des androgynes plus elle est
donc la testostérone était souvent plus
les mêmes un de mes collègues pendant
mon post doc acculant mieux c'est a
nommé un barbu je lui a fait une revue
pendant les années 80 puis à 10 coûtent
ces résultats de testostérone plus élevé
chez les femmes minorités sexuelles
ça pourrait s'expliquer par plein de
facteurs comme le stress mais on sait
que le stress de faire face à plus de
stigma dans ta vie va augmenter le
niveau de testostérone
donc c'est exactement qu'est ce qu'on a
trouvé dans cette étude c'est que les le
monde les femmes lesbiennes et bisexuels
qui avait dit plus de stress au
quotidien avait le niveau de
testostérone plus élevé plus la
progestérone pu arriver il faisait en
sorte qu'ils avaient eu de réponse de
stress plus rêver quand les stresse et
puis si on prend ce concept on dit que
le faire face à du stigma avoir plus de
facteurs comme cela si on prend d'autres
minorités comme comme les différentes
ethnies qui sont en retard parce que
ceux ci a été testé aussi
oui il ya c'est beaucoup de recherche
qui s'intéresse regardez la
discrimination puis c'est assez
semblable qu'est-ce qu'on commence à
voir fichier avec le tgb tic lui plus
mais c'était plus axé sur le
fonctionnement cardiovasculaire un bien
plus grand risque de maladies
cardiovasculaires chez les minorités
dans la sérénité
particulièrement la communauté
afro-américaine qui ont malheureusement
a beaucoup plus de stigma puis il ya
plus beaucoup ces blues plus de la
recherche qui t'ai fait chez eux
donc on mesure
on mesure plus de stress hippie de
stress chronique chez ces groupes le oui
oui puisqu'elle qui va m'en fans c'est
que l'étude que j'ai fait avec son
groupe il ya encore plus de résultats
qui est ressorti de cette étude c'était
une des premières études qui est
vraiment regarder les hormones de stress
en lien avec l'orientation sexuelle
venez au point de communes comme si on
était pour garder le résultat
des hommes gais bisexuels qui avait un
manque de réponse de cortisol du niveau
de pression excusant le pouls plus les
villes on dira peut-être et un profil
malades à petit mais qu'on a regardé la
psychologie avec des questionnaires on
avait des questions de dépression
épuisement professionnel et anxiété puis
on a trouvé même que les hommes gibb
sexuelles étaient moins déprimés que les
hommes hétéros qui fait vraiment
résultat on s'attendait pas à ça comment
est-ce qu'on m'explique
mais je pense c'est un biais de
sélection donc le monde qui a participé
à mon étude on s'entend c'est du monde
qui ont venues à l'hôpital louis h
lafontaine deux fois cinq ans de l'or
comme les nominations ont saigné on
pisse ayant caché pour la salle de la
science à se presser ils ont complété 30
questions et que tu t'es vraiment je les
remercie encore c'était au moins du
monde qui était assise confortable avec
le même de se présenter et puis de
participer à la charge et puis quand on
a fait une analyse de voir qui a fait
complètement leur coming out à leur
famille et à leurs amis quitter la
majorité des hommes gibbs sexuelle eux
ils avaient des niveaux de cortisol plus
bas pendant toute la journée donc on
peut mesurer le cortisone en laboratoire
où on stresse le monde mais on peut
aussi le mesurer au quotidien avec des
échantillons qu'on voit la maison puis
qu'est ce qui est intéressant c'est que
quand cela est beau matin on a une
réponse de stress normal c'est pas
vraiment un stressant c'est juste notre
système qui active et puis c'est ça
montre encore pourquoi le stress immense
cette fois mort
une augmentation de culture elle pourra
être capable d'être cognitivement là
pour commencer notre journée pour
activer notre métabolisme piqué ce qu'on
a trouvé c'est que les gb de notre
échantillon qui avait complètement sorti
du placard avaient des niveaux de
cortisol un peu plus bas dans le matin
comparer ce qui a pas complètement fait
leurs gammes et autres qui conte ahly 1
un niveau plus loin avec une prise de
sang on s'est intéressé à regarder tout
un bilan de biomarqueurs j'aime
enseigner au début à la charge
allostatique c'est c'est vraiment mon
dada tout même recherche synthes cet
index puis qu'est-ce que c'est
essentiellement c'est un index de
fonctionnement physiologique
donc au lieu de juste regarder le
cortisol on s'intéresse à voir reste à
régler sur la pression artérielle la glu
cros l'insuline le système immunitaire
nos facteurs de coagulation donc on a eu
un bilan de vin bio marqueurs c'était
inutile à séchage puis on a qu'est ce
qu'on écrit ça avec cette charge
allostatique c'est ça représente le
nombre de biomarqueurs chez une personne
qui sont un peu déréglé puisqu'elle sont
à trouver c'est que les hommes gais
bisexuels avait une charge allostatique
plus bas que les hommes hétérosexuels
puis tu es vraiment pas un résultat
qu'on s'attendait mais ça c'est que ce
expliqué que c'était vraiment un groupe
on pense qu'ils étaient résilient donc
les gens les individus qui sont venues
des liens et didier parmi ce groupe le
était peut-être rapport à la moyenne de
ce groupe donc tu penses que c'est
peut-être pour cela est une vérité que
dirk émeutes ont en général les hommes
qui seraient moins stressé ou rémy puis
on a eu vraiment un tour médias stephen
crocker a même pris 10 le spin city
comme non c'est pour seul récit post en
question c'est parce que c'est tout
parce que c'est qu'il y avait vraiment
une analyse between groupe ce qui était
hétérosexuel comparer aux 1 gb d'après
une analyse whitten groupe ce qui était
sgb sorti du placard ou non donc ce que
c'est
c'est à expliquer tout ça aux médias
c'était tellement drôle parce que
c'était publiée dans journal sacrement
avec mme hansen qui est un nom un peu ça
fait un peu qu'un mot c'est dans ta tête
puis la journée même la société du
journal avait un vote pour changer leur
nom parce qu'il trouvait tête on devrait
tous accros sochaux puis stink robert
yamen l'étude puis dix enfants ne faut
pas de kent nelson fabrication en série
culte
c'étaient tous des faits étaient faits
au canada donc on doit attendre que
c'était tout se fait en résumé c'est
exactement ce que j'ai fait pendant mon
post doc je suis intéressé de voir est
ce que les résultats seraient semblables
aux états unis puis qu'est ce que j'ai
fait au canada c'était un petit
échantillon de 87 personnes
c'était quand même une étude très cher
mais ça reste que pour muter limité avec
le monde qu'on pourrait prendre
donc j'ai fait une collaboration avec
des chercheurs à l'université de
californie à los angeles qui avait accès
à des données de 13000 américains puis
on était capable de calculer à charge
allostatique puis qu'est-ce qu'on a
trouvé c'était encore la même chose les
hommes gays avaient une charge
allostatique plus bas que les hommes
hétérosexuels mais parce qu'on avait un
plus large échantillon on était capable
d'avoir plusieurs groupes de réinsertion
sexuelle donc on allait hétérosexuels
bisexuels homosexuels un autre groupe
est super intéressant mme ostria de
ressac chose donc ceux qui sont vraiment
bisexuels pas complètement et héros
parce qu'ils ont eu des expériences
puisqu'elle sont à trouver c'est que
chez les bisexuels c'était les hommes
bisexuels qui avait une charge
allostatique lui et que toutes les
autres groupes tout c'est intéressant
parce que être bisexuelle c'est d'être
une main un groupe majoritaire d'un
groupe minoritaire mais ne reçoit pas
les mêmes ressources de soutien souvent
t-il les ongs et vautours dira c'est un
appel peut pas choisir
c'est un peu malheureusement énormément
de préjugés contre l'accusé
bisexuelle donc ça c'est que ça pourrait
s'expliquer à ce niveau là mais l'autre
explication c'est que comme j'ai dit
auparavant les langues et les anglais
ont la culture et fait un peu plus
attention à leur diète alors
alimentation qui tous les biomarqueurs
qu'on regardait c'était cholestérol
index masse corporelle pressant aux tn
donc ça pourrait s'expliquer de l'autre
côté les femmes c'est fascinant à quel
point ici tout est tellement mills
factorielle c'est dur de mettre le doigt
sur exactement ce que nous on n'a pas
trouvé différents chez les femmes dans
mon étude avec son nez avec les
montréalais denis avec l'étude avec les
américains
pas de chance les femmes en lien avec
l'orientation sexuelle donc oui à la
petite variation en terme de leur charge
allostatique mais on n'a pas trouvé de
différence basée sur l'orientation
sexuelle puis ça c'est je pense on a
besoin d'aller plus loin dans l'avenir
pour comprendre plus d'autres facteurs
de stigma port donc tout ça moi c'est
des études où l'on regarde les groupes
mais chaque groupe a vraiment un
contexte de facteurs psychosocial puis
de comportements qui sont assez uniques
qu'on n'est pas capable de vraiment
regarder dans une grosse enquête plus
superficielle mais donc un truc été fait
aux états unis il ya une chanson qui est
assez groupe est assez varié pour qu'on
soit assez certains des résultats
finalement oui ça pose la question
qu'est ce qui explique ça moi ça c'est
un peu le mélange entre la santé
publique qui souvent va avoir des
grosses enquêtes des gros échantillons
mais qui va manquer un peu la machine de
précision donc ça s'apprend du monde on
y re séance comme que moi comme sonia
qui qui compliments un peu les résultats
avec incompréhension plus haut niveau
mais qu'à nice 2 qu'est ce qui se passe
chez les yeux et où c'est un niveau
biologique
mais quand on parle de mettons deux
de dépression d'anxiété 2 est ce que les
groupes s les minorités sexuelles en
vivent davantage où on remarque peut
donc généralement qu'est ce qu'on voit
dans la littérature de santé publié
classe la littérature puisque logique
c'est que il ya plus de stieg manche et
la cnil tgb ti-cul plus non plus de ce
type de troubles de santé mentale
exactement qui exactement sursaut sur
les questionneurs plus de dépression
plus donc c'était plus de toxicomanie
mais qu'est ce qui est unique avec cette
recherche qu'on fait c'est que qu'est ce
qu'on voit au niveau physiologique
c'est quelque chose de différent puis ça
c'est intéressant parce qu'on peut on
peut être résilient au niveau des troncs
d'abord fonctionnement physiologique qui
fonctionne bien mais que notre santé
montables peu soir bien donc je vous
donne un exemple qui revient au racisme
aux états unis est un concept très
intéressant
johnny nous sommes donc johnny neige pas
si c'est quelqu'un qui était vraiment si
c'est un caractère fictionnel mais
c'était un homme noir qui travaille sur
les faire je mène pas chemin de fer puis
apparemment l'histoire ses qualités en
compétition contre une machine qui a
battu la machine puis une fois qui a
battu la machine il y a crevé
d'épuisement du john and within c'est
l'idée que certains individus la
communauté noire voire capable de
réussir bien à l'école ou bien réussir
et collectivement avec leurs travaux
mais ça va venir avec un prix puis un
chercheur par le nom de brûlis qui s'est
vraiment intéressé de voir un mélange de
succès académique symptomatologie
psychiatrique et charge allostatique
puis qu'est-ce qui a trouvé chez des
adolescents noirs dans les quartiers
plus défavorisés c'est que ceux qui
avaient moins de symptômes externalisée
donc moins de délinquance moyenne 9
colère qui réussissait bien à l'école
avait une charge allostatique plus et
donc c'est un exemple de comment le sell
in south beach ça dépend vraiment du
contexte le moment il ya dans l'article
c'est la question qui est devant
et puis on pourrait imaginer ce commencé
à se manifester d'autres communautés
minoritaires et aussi le concept d'
intersexualité trois cantons ouais donc
être une femme noire lesbienne c'est un
mélange de d'identité droit sigma a un
coût de l'ordre est exactement puis on
en parle beaucoup de intéresse
intersexualité c'est un concept qui
n'eut plus de 2 contre courant féministe
ou une femme noire se trouvait que le à
l'époque tu le fais mine et c'était très
blanc puis ça prenait pas en compte le
contexte de race des nécessités puis
c'est vraiment le mélange identité et
puis je suis retourné à mon résultat de
sortir du placard qui au moyen d'un
échantillon de montréal est on trouve
que sortir du placard et est relié à des
niveaux de cortisol plus bas est aussi
une santé mentale plus forte donc moins
d'anxiété - dépression et moyen des
primes en professeur et un autre groupe
qui a faim ni d'avoir mois aux
etats-unis ou à raison on a quand même
un état qui ont
ils ont trouvé que les hommes qui
avaient sorti du placard au travail
avait plus de problèmes de santé mentale
et les niveaux de cortisol plus élevé
donc voilà même vous de personnes mais
je vous en conjure graphiquement sont
dans un autre en californie versus
arizona exact d'autres personnes ont
regardé mon résultat de sortir du
placard est bon pour la santé
puis on dit ouais mais peut-être rôle du
monde qui ont un statut socio économique
plus fort est en effet la majorité de
musique mais mes participants étaient du
monde à universitaire donc déjà un
niveau c'est un peu plus ludique que la
langue donc tout ça se mélange d'être
une minorité sexuelle
une minorité de rasées suscité mélanger
aussi avec status of economic où tu
habites on s'entend que ma recherche
pourrait pas se faire facilement on
arrive bissau dit
mais donc la grande ligne qu'on peut
tirer c'est qu'évidemment c'est pas
normal
l'orientation sexuelle en soi qui vont
modifier un peu la réponse de stress
mais plutôt stigmatiser galles seul
point clé on dirait le connaissez vous
le nom donc ce tournoi est je crois
c'était en 1969 c'était ton noir c'était
un bar c'est toujours le bord je pense
que j'espère qu'ils vont rester ouverts
à new york puis c'était un bar qui se
faisait vraiment lui aidé par la police
puis un soir s'il avait un genre de
budget au pas des gens mais un jour de
commémoration pour inscrire son nom la
maire de lille ce mardi
je ne peux pas t'aider oublier
complètement son nom c'est là c'est
l'actrice qui était dans liza minnelli
connaît google moi c'est mon cas où elle
a marre de dyson les écoutes liza
minnelli manama j'ai eu complètement
oublié son nom entre elles étaient morts
oui oui qui joue à la celtitude un don
qui l'accusé étaient rassemblés pour
vraiment c était très libre et très
triste parce que c'était vraiment un
leader pour la cnps tig et puis la
police à rentrer puis on nous dit enfin
puis ça a commencé à un gros wright qui
est vraiment poussé les droits civils
aux états unis dont on parle souvent de
ce tournoi pour moi
puis chaque ville en amérique du nord a
eu leur propre histoire donc montréal on
avait eu un toronto san francisco donc
pendant mon post doctorat quand j'étais
à new york
j'ai fait des entrevues avec du monde
quitter aston donc on avait un
échantillon de 60 lesbiennes et de gays
qui était un mélange de personnes
blanches et blancs noirs et hispaniques
et puis qu'est-ce qu'on a trouvé qui
vraiment intéressant j'ai besoin de
publier donc je dis que c'est un
résultat qui a besoin d'être mais ça
reste quand même que le résultat est là
on a trouvé sur un questionnaire de
discrimation le plus d'identité que la
personne rapportait d'être stigmatisés
donc leur âge leur race ou d'ethnie cité
leur orientation sexuelle leur identité
de genre le plus dense et qui disait qu
qui se sentaient être affecté le niveau
de cortisol était plus élevé donc ça
répond exactement à votre question que
c'est d'avoir une identité qui
stigmatise et qui va faire en sorte
qu'on va voir une augmentation de 2
de cortisol c'est fascinant de mettre le
doigt sur ce on dirait pi2 dans la
compréhension du truc de dire que dans
une société juste par la culture puis la
façon avec laquelle on voit les
minorités que ce soit sexuelle ou de
race ou même l'imam l'ailé
les minorités et systématisée de d'âge
que cela ait d'impact réel sur le neuf
un facteur de stress mais plus largement
ta santé plus largement les troubles de
santé mentale puisque c'est calculable
big on le voit puis qu'au final c'est
dans tout dans tout le temps toute
l'idée d'accepter les minorités quelle
qu'elle soit c'est un facteur ultra
important que de dire c'est aussi un
aspect de santé de société c'est un
aspect de république de santé publique
le truc exactement puis c'est juste beau
geste social en fait il faut juste
l'aspect sociologique de dire acceptons
les gens comme ils sont aussi aussi un
aspect de santé publique exactement
c'est fou c'est exactement la façon que
j'ai j'ai fini là mon premier article
avec sonia j'ai dit comme état de cause
il faut se sentir bien pour le phare
premièrement donc si on habite dans un
environnement où se sent pas à l'aise de
le faire on va pas le faire donc j'ai
dit dès mardi
en effet c'est exactement qu'est ce que
je pense puis je donner un autre exemple
recherche avec un de mes collaborateurs
razak 8 du bois à lui se dit de bouëx
parce que bon ici aux etats-unis metz
c'est vraiment du bois
même avec des buts b capital c'est quoi
le but charpy dans le bol
c'est surtout ça qui a fait 1 étude
vraiment intéressant pendant son dock
c'est un autre pilote biologique donc il
s'intéressait à voir chez les autres en
jean donc femmes natale qui pensaient
transitionnelle pour être un depuis il
s'intéressa à voir leurs expériences de
transition avec des entrevues qualitatif
et aussi avec l'échantillonnage de
biomarqueurs donc lui a regardé le
cortisol et regarder aussi
fonctionnement cardiovasculaire puis
qu'est-ce qu'on a trouvé dans un de ces
analyses
c'était que les intrants gens qui
rapportait plus de stress en lien avec
leurs transitions plus de stress en lien
avec leur caméra depuis plus de stress
en lien avec les layettes walla publics
avaient des niveaux que de corseul plus
lévis que ceux qui avaient moins de
stress puis c'était tout fait dans des
éditeurs assez libérale donc vermont
alive and massachusetts puis c'est
vraiment ça montre à quel point beaucoup
de facteurs qu'on est en train d'avoir
des débats politiques
mais non c'est ça un effet direct sur le
cortisol de la personne puis on a un
autre a cuit puis notre collègue jean
paquette à universciné schengen et on
fait tout une enquête qui continuent
actuellement aux etats-unis de l'état de
ouargla l'état de michigan leurs
méthodes tennessee puis je m'en tiens un
autre aussi je sais pas c'est quoi
mais il s'intéresse à voir la cnps et
étrange en énorme dinars avant
l'élection dont de voir tous les
changements dans leur santé en lien avec
d'ailleurs qui va plus être la crise
c'est aujourd'hui jeudi sur une cible
acheté mon compte
j'essaie de pas boire de champagne
aujourd'hui par l'enquêté président
écoute
c'était tellement la soirée où était élu
écoutez c'était tellement un traumatisme
la ville de new york la journée après
c'était une journée c'est un nul et je
plonge je me semble émotive y penser
écoute c'était tellement c'était
traumatique de boire comment la ville de
new york
même une vie libéral était affecté par
cette élection puis au début on cydia il
va pas être très il va peut rien faire
pour la cnhi tgbt m'écoute mike pence et
un zèle est pinilla vraiment fait du
dommage pour la cnhi tgbt
particulièrement à culte étrange ans est
nominé lui macpaint c'était pour la la
thérapie de conversion ne mange pas
certain que lui en avais faire au
parquet
ça fait je suis absent dix ans qui bat
le plaqueur pique ses hormones de stress
seront sensibles juste pour dire comme
l'homophobie
il ya la recherche qui a montré à quel
point l'homophobie est souvent relié à
la turbie internaliser il ya même une
étude l homophobie est relié est relié à
l'homosexualité refoulée exact j'ai une
étude même qui a regardé cette question
me jean un élastique métalliques sur les
pénis de deux participants pillon
c'était des patients bien qu'aucun cas
de calculer la tension cool pillon prix
à du monde hétérosexuels dumont gueye
puis du monde qui tu es vraiment qu'un
homo public gay puis ont trouvé c'est
pas vraiment surprenant que les hommes
au fond d'équité exposés à du point la
guerre il avait des petites érection qui
se passait donc c'est pas tout le temps
le cas je pense y ait des raisons
surtout culturelle c'est les sociétés un
peu macho ce n'importe quelle société
qui traite les femmes comme deuxième
citoyen j'avais même société qui traite
la quinte j'ai buté mal pensé vous
pourrez utiliser l élection son élection
finalement vraiment qui pourraient
peut-être être mesuré les réponses de
stress le chiffre verticalement la clint
30 puis c'est pour ça que les accus et
puis dj sont intéressés de regarder à
clint avec la charge allostatique avec
le cordial mais aussi avec des entrevues
qualitatif avec des questionnaires puis
maintenant avec l'élection de baleines
qui bientôt va être
marguerite on voit capable avec le temps
de voir si une diminuation de stress
chez la cliente et puis ça s'est
vraiment pas important parce que content
de stigma on parle vraiment de on peut
parler de stigma internaliser donc à
quel point je me sens internats dont
cameron tient un stigma un peu
internaliser parce que le processus du
caméo tsé-tsé très interne puis après si
c'est vraiment plus un niveau plus
macroscopique que soit ton environnement
ta famille tes amis tes collègues mais
un niveau plus large que ça c'est le
stigma structurelles
donc c'est quoi les lois en place qui ne
m'attache communauté c'est quoi les lois
qui sont allés enlever qui qu'est ce que
mike pence avait fait d'une manière très
très couverte
il était très efficace mike pence à
faire ces dommages là donc le stigma
structurelles plus mesurée en regardant
un certain moment dans le temps
bacchetta aux états unis c'est quoi les
lois qui protègent puis un ami et mentor
à columbia c'est un chercheur pour le
nom de marque catherine bürki vraiment
la personne
iter connaît bien maintenant c'est rare
bird donc ça donne une idée de type lui
il capable de avec plusieurs indices de
loi donc dix doigts différent de voir
c'est quoi le stigma structurelle d'un
et un certain moment puis qu'est ce
qu'ils trouvent c'est que c'était un
minorités sexuelles dans les tops avec +
s'estimant structurelles qui souvent les
hits plus rouge tu as une santé mentale
plus faute puis aussi un risque de
mortalité plus qu'est-ce-qui super
intéressant c'est que ça change donc lui
s'intéressait devoir des états qui ont
mis en place le mariage gay qui ont
trouvé que l'une d'innovation de stress
et de problèmes de santé mentale chez
les les états où il y avait
un changement exactement donc ça c'est
quelque chose que je mettais savoir avec
marc de regarder segment structurels aux
états unis donc 2001 puis 2014 puis
regardez la charge allostatique puis
qu'est-ce qu'on soupçonne c'est que ce
qui a eu dans des états avec plus de six
segments structurelles vont avoir une
charge allostatique privé puissance et
je vois pas ça comme des rots et ses
plus importants la bio marque les
biomarqueurs et plus important c'est la
recherche vraiment complémentaires à
tout qui se fait en santé publique tout
ce qui se fait au niveau psychologique
est-ce que tu parles de deux facteurs de
style mans et maquereau le terme est
utilisé les médecins stigma structure
voix l'estimant structurel est ce qu'il
ya eu des études qui ont été faites sur
les communautés autochtones dans le
monde très bonne classe qu'il est parce
que au niveau structurel si bien des
gens qui sont stigmatisés c'est laid
comme notre questionnement
j'ai un collègue ou en australie autre
enseigne équité inconnu titans de bruce
lee kyou le grand globe en place il
s'intéresse à voir chez les unités
autochtones australien la chaleur
fatigue chez jésus en lien avec la
discrimination mais je de mes
connaissances je connais je connais pas
du monde qui ont vraiment regarder
vraiment intéressant de comparer une
société comme la nouvelle zélande
risques et les maoris sont beaucoup
mieux intégrés dans la société c'est pas
nous y verse que s'épanouit versus ici
ou est ce qu'il ya des réserves puissent
et structurellement vraiment imminent
vers eux j'essaie pop chez les unités
autochtone mais y'a qu'il ya de la
recherche qui s'intéressent à regarder
l'égalité de genre au même niveau donc
on parle de deux genres institutionnels
donc les lillois qui sont en place qui
ne permettent pas donc les îles droit de
réduction c'est un exemple excellent
pour les femmes
il ya beaucoup de variations aux états
unis qui est quelqu'un qui sait de boire
institutional gender un niveau de ckoi
la représentation de femmes
politiquement dans un espace
c'est quoi les doigts en place qui
protègent ou non les droits de
reproduction puis qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
trouvée c'est que les états qui avaient
moins de 2 de gender institutions
afghanes de donc moins de stigma
structurelles avait une santé mentale
plus mr donc cet été dans un état qui
avait plus de l'institution allait bien
donc moins de loi qui protégeait terrain
de santé mentale plus plus pauvres aux
états unis est assez facile justement
comme tout donateur à l'autre or une
étude qui va être content mariage qu'il
ya une route non c'est assez facile de
le voir c'était stigma structurel est ce
que au québec il y en a encore un
stigmate structurelles puis si oui quel
est-il mais je sais je retourne françois
legault qui disait qu'il n'y a pas de
racisme au québec c'est sur rien on peut
le calculer dans la racine des cheveux
ou des viandes
si tu veux je pense il en reste toujours
pu même avec l'allié dit qu'ils
pourraient être faits et indiquer de
racisme épauler racisme ici d'un whisky
tous ces jouets clément mais oui minutes
c'est un super bon presse et puis ça
revient encore à quai ce que je parle de
ce type non structurelle parce que l'on
parle d'eux le système c'est la semaine
c'est vraiment la structure puis oui je
pense il sait on
pour tout payer lgbt je pense qu on est
quand même les choses vont assez bien il
ya quand même un progrès qui s'avance
mais ça reste quand même qu'il ya encore
du travail à faire je pense même chose
pour le racisme même chose pour les
liquidités autochtone s'il ya encore
beaucoup de travail à faire dans
n'importe quelle société
je pense qu'on a un peu la tendance au
canada de dire à retient les américains
on se sent un peu comme on est les
voisins
d'un maître la bombe nous les voisins
wow que si on a quand même nos problèmes
même de regarder une carte géographique
du canada avec qui a voté en faveur du
mariage gay est ce que des études qui
ont été faites en alberta sur la
stigmatisation sculpture culturel
structurelles disque une bonne question
parce que probablement que les résultats
sont politiques au québec
oui exactement car aucun indice mais
c'est aussi ça dépend t il va voir
certaines parties de cadbury qui va être
un peu plus progressif si l'on parle de
texas il ya quand même des villes assez
progressif à theix et s'intitule même où
on est dans un état était très différent
pied où on est plus rural vers c'est sûr
mais est très important aussi c'est on
dirait que c'est comme une façon de
calculer le racisme ou de calculer nos
folies l'homophobie ou de calculer les
teams étant d'être capable de quelques
subtils les comparer à des endroits dans
le monde sait on dirait que c'est comme
être capable calcul à un niveau de 1
niveau réel genre tangible de c'est quoi
l'amour sans citer ces discussions qui
sont dans l'air du temps on n'a pas
souvent cité pisi tr6 et très
sociologiques comme question mais en
même temps le tout arrive de background
scientifi ques que si parce que c'est
mesurables on arrive un plus aux mêmes
conclusions finalement c'est vraiment
fascinant de voir justement ti comme les
terrasses intersexualité par exemple
c'est quelque chose qu'on parle mais le
droit de comprendre qu'ils ont quant eux
tels étaient les tl stigma mis ensemble
ça augmente
tt tt tant au niveau de stress de stress
chronique cc vraiment cérences pas
facilement j'ai un exemple une étude
avec une laboratoire new york university
c'est stéphanie coq puis elle
s'intéresse beaucoup le mélange des
trains minorités sexuelles homme et être
noir versus blanc puis on a fait une
analyse on l'a gardé le cortisol au
quotidien donc d'ailleurs non creusot
c'est le nom dont on comprend un
échantillon ou les verts
et trente minutes après appui avant
d'aller au lit
qu'est ce qu'on a trouvé c'est que chez
les hommes qui ont sexe avec des sommes
quittés et noir il avait un manque de
cortisol doucement il avait un courtisan
un profil clôture un peu aplatie
il y avait moins de variations pendant
la journée qui faisait en sorte que
avant d'aller au lit leurs niveaux de
cortisol était plus est la plus élevée
que les hommes blancs ça c'est quelque
chose qui a été montré dans la
littérature sur la discrimination que
souvent le cortisol avant d'aller au lit
c'est souvent un peu plus sensibles à la
discrimination puis c'est intéressant
parce que c'est un exemple
l'intersexualité que on a un mélange de
rater sismicité et d'orientation
sexuelle etc
c'est tous des hommes qui ont sexe avec
des amis c'est le terme qui utilisent et
plus en recherche comportementale men
who have sex with men au lieu de
conception qui c'est un exemple de
comment on peut faire de la recherche
intersectionnelle mais ça prend des
grosses sessions sont pas ce qu'on veut
c'est sûr l'idéal ça aurait été d'abord
un groupe hétérosexuels
d'abord des femmes c'était bien d'avoir
ce genre de mélange puis l'intersection
est et reste quand même très difficile à
mesurer
un niveau santé publique avec des
données quantitatives
c'est le concept d' intersexualité on en
parle beaucoup dans la recherche
qualitative puis beaucoup en recherche
sociologique de le mesurer c'est souvent
ici mais je pense qu'on peut le faire
puis une façon c'est vraiment d'indexer
le nombre d'identités minoritaires une
personne
la semaine dernière on en a reçu le rémi
quirion qu'elle est scientifique en chef
du québec puissent pas fini à chaque
fois qu'on redonne son titre séché avec
le collectif mais lui parlait que de
plus en plus en recherche pour lui
favorisé ce que différents départements
ce travail ensemble très contaminante et
donc toi sciences naturelles sciences
humaines sociologie avec science exacte
de russian donc si sa vison donc et
mickaël c'est drôle it et le directeur
scientifique du de l'opt ados bliss
canson de la piété l'appui je me suis
une fois paraît qu'il signe un document
pour une demande de subvention qui
gérons dans son bureau
écoute j'étais blanc départ toutes les
trophées tout efficace et alix tout le
monde le sait pas mais rémy keon c'est
un des neuroscientifiques le plus cité
au monde sa recherche il ya arrêté plus
de sa recherche pour devenir son écoute
tout qui fait actuellement avec les faq
c'est vraiment de favoriser des
subventions qui mélange des disciplines
différentes donc il ya des mécanismes
qui s'appelle les deux mondes audace
j'applique et puis on peut donner
l'argent mais voilà c'est quoi le projet
c'était un projet pour avec les
microbiologistes de voir le microbiome
et esnal chez la culte étrangères en
transition parce qu'on sait que le
microbiome et et cela c'est tout plat
les fleurissements diversité de
microbiologie chromie de microbes
microbes dans notre estomac puis s'est
largement affecté par notre stress c'est
aussi affecté par les hormones sexuelles
donc on s'est dit ça serait vraiment
intéressant de voir si la culte étrange
hante à ce qu il ya une diminuation de
stress avec la transition mais il ya un
changement d'hormones sexuelles
un dessin ton souvent chez lacunes
titrant genre masculin c'est des
problèmes digestifs et des problèmes de
douleur puis des problèmes immunitaires
donc on s'est dit ça pourrait être un
niveau super important pour la clint da
capable de faire cette recherche mais
aussi au niveau fondamental ça permet de
voir comment les homosexuels puis le
microbiome pileux corticeira j étais
réagi mais
malheureusement pas les humains on a eu
un petit fond de nous verser montréal
les questions que je vais te poser c'est
est ce que toi mettons dans ta recherche
en neurosciences été amenés à travailler
avec méthode et justement des gens issus
des sciences humaines ou tuer ce qu'est
ce qui lie à ce dialogue le oui oui puis
à moi personnellement la recherche
transdisciplinaire c'est vraiment la
preuve que je prends donc pour moi juste
pour la question de stress on peut
regarder le stress une perspective
environnementale
on peut regarder sans une perspective
psychologique avec des questionnaires
son échelle de 1 à 5 je suis stressé
puis l'autre c'est vraiment biologique
puis je pense être capable de mélanger
tout ça ensemble ça donne une
perspective plus politique sans être un
peu quétaine
t'es où c'est vraiment ça nous donne une
perspective plus personnalisé de
l'individu puis cette approche me
permettent vraiment de faire la
recherche avec du monde en travail
social donc l'une mes collègues c'est
annie poulain sansfaçon 1 en travail
social de murcie de montréal qui
s'intéressent chez les jeunes trans et
leurs familles quand j'ai rencontré
annie la première fois que j'arrive avec
tout ce qu'en disait il a sali puis le
microbiome ça pis si on réalise qu'on
est en train de répondre des mêmes
questions
c'est le but finalement c'est de
comprendre comment le stigma affecte
notre santé parlait pas le même langage
mais vous parlez de même chez exact
exactement donc je pense d'abord cette
perspective transdisciplinaire ça
permette d'ouvrir des portes puis je
suis pas un expert dans tout ce que je
fais mais je suis capable de au moins
savoir comment dira bonjour konichiwa
type le mans certains langages de mes
collègues de plus en plus on va voir ces
gens de recherche favorisés c'est
vraiment intéressant parce que steam
j'aimerais avec soignants de plus si
vraiment traité de comment le stress
fonctionne dans une voie un être humain
d'un individu comment comment comment ça
se manifeste
comment qu'ont pu apprendre le délai
puis l'heure on en est à la conversation
sur kim après ce qu'elles sont les
groupes thé dans la société qui sont le
plus affectés par ce peuple et ça permet
d'avoir vraiment une perspective globale
de ce pied après ceux justement ils sont
se racontent certains certains groupes
plus touchés mais après ce qu'est ce
qu'on fait avec cbs que 6,6
structurelles sqbb est le nouveau les
lois qu est ce qu il faut changer si sa
demie vraiment je te mentir super
espoirs intéressant la thune
moi j'ai une question par rapport à la
charge et l'oust oléo statique à l'eau
sept allostatique et puis sept chargeurs
qui est calculable quel effet elles
qu'elles sont quels en sont les effets
sur le long terme donc moi c'est cela
change allostatique a été créé pour sa
réponse le plus apte à création du sur
le vieillissement ouais c'est ça
semblait deux affaires qui ont la charge
allostatique le facteur qui prédit une
charge aussi que le plus fort sill loges
dont le plus qu'on vieillit le plus que
nationaux s'attaque va augmenter puis le
concept a été créé vraiment pour
comprendre le capable d'avoir une
meilleure capacité de prédire des
maladies reliées au stress chez ali
population rage et donc il y avait un
étude car ferries succès c'était des
petits vieux qui allait assez bien de
leur santé allaient assez bien il
s'intéressa à voir est ce qu'on est
capable de prédire qui va développer des
problèmes cognitifs qui va mourir puis y
ont créé la charge de celle ci serait
capable de calculer qui beau monde et
c'est ça qui ont fait rapport grignon
prix n'ont pris 10 bio marqueurs
différents donc cholestérol
triglycérides ioukos cortisol adrénaline
qui sont sûrs a été été dans la salle
quand il était en train de faire c'est
sonia l'a vécu cette ville
le 150 à la chambre les statiques la
plus basse de l'histoire c'est quand
même quelqu'un comme l'a dit son
émission c'est quand même quelqu'un qui
fait face au stress ou à n'importe qui
mais c'est juste que c'est pas le stress
les pauvres vu comme manas est
surmontable pour
donc il s'intéresse à utiliser cet index
pour prédire les trucs puis qu'est-ce
qu'ils ont trouvée c'est que même dans
un échantillon de 1000 personnes qui
allaient assez bien en santé la chambre
ou statique qui regardaient pas juste
des biomarqueurs qui était cliniquement
cinkassé qu'est ce qui est on a que mme
avantage avec un index et charlot
statique c'est que on est en train de
regarder plusieurs biomarqueurs
donc c'est pas juste cortisol ou juste
cholestérol mais aussi on est en train
de regarder des créateurs un peu saoul
clinique
donc j'aurai un exemple si tu veux voir
ton docteur python que les stérols et
5.2 ils vont mettre un cercle qui veut
dire que ton crécerelle élevé mais
qu'est ce qu'il ya quelqu'un avec 4.7
sais c'est pas cliniquement
significatifs mais ça ça s'approche donc
l'index de charge allostatique nous
permet de prendre en compte des systèmes
qui sont un peu ça fonctionne posture
bien pour être capable de prédire des
maladies puis qu'est ce qu'ils ont
trouvé avec cet index qui représente le
nombre de biomarqueurs qui sont déréglés
pour un individu une charge de satik
plus libye était relié à plus de
maladies cardiovasculaires plus de
déclin en commission plus de problèmes
en déclin physique physique en cause mon
carlotti donc n'importe quelle cause de
mortalité puis on fait ça bx line trois
ans c'est tant pis 12 ans puis le
résultat était toujours exactement la
même chose il y avait des petites
variations en termes de race ethnicité
et puis de sexe donc essentiellement ça
c'étaient les premières études pour voir
le vieillissement qu'il a changé le
statique puis c'était répliqué
internationalement il ya eu des études
ou taiwan en allemagne en europe qui moi
je me suis intéressé de voir ça avec le
stress au travail
donc on a fait une étude pendant ma
maîtrise avec sonia pouvoir
le burn out qui on a trouvé que chez une
population âgée qu'elle soit palpable
est archi apparition travailleurs et
travailleuses que une charge
allostatique été relief plus de bonheur
qui étaient reliés à des niveaux de
clôture le plus bas
ça c'est une ligne de recherche que je
continue actuellement avec une 1800
philip kerr qui s'intéressent à voir la
relation entre les antidépresseurs et le
cortisol et à l'épuisement professionnel
est aussi en charge allostatique le but
not la dépression et sont inversés je
crois dans le niveau culturel sexy donc
des pressions c'est généralement les
niveaux de cortisol élevé qu'on voit
puis l'épuisement professionnel c'est
complètement la pause j'ai toujours
pensé c'était des synonymes mes petites
mains mais bien fondé des prêts sans
atypique qui est relié à des niveaux de
cordes salle burke je crois est vraiment
d'épuisement professionnel
c'est vraiment important au niveau du 4
x 4 donc je peux pas parler de tout ça
mais j'ai quand même une opinion que
j'en parle à quelqu'un qui en arrêt de
travail au québec généralement ces trois
mois d'arrêt de travail souvent
quelqu'un va être prescrit des
antidépresseurs n'apprend environ un
mois avant que les antidépresseurs
fonctionne mais les antidépresseurs par
mécanisme de sérotonine va diminuer les
niveaux de cortisol peut-être pas une
bonne chose pour quelqu'un à lui du
niveau déjà bas il ya des chercheurs en
scandinavie qui s'intéressent à donner
le corps synthétique donc la cortisone à
des patients qui ont un arrêt de travail
l'épuisement projet simple qu'est ce
qu'ils voient c'est que leur cortisol
remonte mais leurs symptômes
d'épuisement procès diminue donc c'est
un peu fade in fire with fire 2 mai donc
des fois on confond les deux flamandes
qui pourrait lui être un épuisement
professionnel mais il diagnostiqué une
dépression pour se donner des
antidépresseurs ouais ça c'est vous
c'est vraiment important mon avis de
regarder le corps tout seul donc souvent
les pilotes vont peut-être j'ai pas le
temps de faire un échantillonnage de
claude sommes écoute toute cette perte
de temps de donner des médicaments qui
font que c'est un beau bien donc ça
serait idéalement ça serait tellement
fantastique si on avait plus de deux
mesures comme le cortisol
dans les cliniques pour être capable de
vraiment personnalisé l'approchent
médicales et aussi la proche puisque le
jeu que je pensais certaines personnes
qui vont réagir à des thérapies
psychothérapique d'une manière
différente qui va dépenses sur leur
personnalité donc l'important c'est
vraiment d'avoir dans mon avis pas juste
la bio mais aussi des questionneurs
d'avoir un contexte social
c'est pourquoi le tout la recherche
transdisciplinaire est tellement
important que tu parlais des la charge
allostatique kiki qui est un bon
indicateur du vieillissement qui tout à
l'heure on parlait de plus de ce fait
face à des stigmas plus ta charge
allostatique est élevé est ce que dans
ces études là qui trace la charge
allostatique est ce qu'on a remarqué des
différences en terme de déclin ou 2
d'augmentation de la chaleur ou statique
selon les minorités qui font face à des
steam c'est une bonne question qui ça de
mes connaissances avait pas été regardé
les études qui regardent la charge lors
statique avec le temps on est vraiment
juste en émergence il y avait une étude
qui quand je commençais ma carrière qui
a montré que chez le peuple à son âge et
si elle une diminuation de cortisol
excuse moi une diminution de charge
allostatique pour n'importe quelle
raison la santé mentale puis la santé
physique à la mieux c'est pas surprenant
mais c'est cool quand même que men
population âgée est ce qu est ce qui m
est temps d'être un groupe qui vit
difficilement est-ce qu'on voit un effet
sur l'espérance de vie
oh oui oui absolument absolument pied à
charge allostatique c'est vraiment
intéressant parce que les sait capables
de vraiment détecter la même la
mortalité comme j'ai dit il ya des
études qui ont regardé la combinaison
d'être quelqu'un qui est pauvre plus
race non blancs puis comment ça c'est
relié à chanteloup statique qui reliait
la mortalité
puis on trouve et je me souviens pas
exactement le chief mais d'être noirs et
pauvres aux états unis ça augmente et on
laisse de moins jeunes plus jeunes
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup plus et c'est
vraiment important pour je pense les
communautés minoritaires de race
technicité c'est exceptionnellement
important pour les incultes et
d'autochtones
parce que s'il ya vraiment une
innovation pied ou si les populations
qui a pris énormément de je pense de
population où on a des avantages puis la
charge érotique nous permette vraiment
d'avoir cedex objectif maintenant sa
demande
et comme en plus diminuer la charge
cette sécu on est vraiment au début de
faire des recherches qui s'intéresse à
sa puis avec mes utilisant filets peu
que j'ai mentionnés on s'intéresse à
voir si la charge allostatique peut
prédire qui va répondre mieux aux
antidépresseurs ou non quels facteurs
dans la chance de le pratiquer est ce
que c'est le cortisol ou est ce que
c'est une inflammation qui voient
capable de prédire tout ça mais la
recherche qui rentre avec une
intervention il y en a pas beaucoup
j'ai fait partie d'une avec un collègue
aux états unis qui regardaient
l'ostéopathie mais c'est un échantillon
avec deux personnes
on a trouvé une diminuation donc le
monde qui subit à des traitements si
apathiques il y avait une génération de
charge cette section un homme cherche
l'âme on aimerait faire ça avec le plus
large échantillon mais c'est ça le but
finalement ça va être à l'avenir de voir
comment on peut diminuer une charge ça
c'est piqué c'est quoi les facteurs qui
peut le faire puis il ya toutes les
facteurs individuels il ya tout les
comportements de santé individuel mais
aussi au niveau système
oui c'est ce qui
ce qui me fera vendre est ce qu'on parle
c'est qu'elle est on sait tous sauté on
le mesure où l'on observe on voit sur la
mortalité des gens ces sinistres plus
que ça de le bouter éditorial du poker
mondial c'est tellement fort chaki rien
de plus que ce soit fait sachant tout ce
n'est pas plus de mesures et de lois
d'action politique sachant tous août
non je pense une façon de d'essayer de
comprendre ça c'est sûr c'est pau on
s'intéresse beaucoup à la lune vérité
puis beaucoup de caisses que j'ai parlé
aujourd'hui c'est un peu c'est très doux
ming lunda être en minorité soit relié à
nice reste privé et aussi énormément de
résilience
puis ça c'est quelque chose qui
m'intéresse beaucoup dans mon
laboratoire
j'ai deux étudiants extrait c'est quand
tu traites de résidents je suis juste
pour faire la [ __ ] menteuse qu'un titre
it de résilience dans ce contexte la
caisse que quiconque comment ça se
matérialise me tombent donc la
résilience comme définition que
j'utilise c'est la capacité de phares
huit bandes après un stress et puis
essentiellement pour être résilient faut
avoir fait face à du stress de
l'adversité dutronc l'idée de région
c'est que on est capable de mieux gérer
nos stresseurs à l'avenir puis comme
j'ai dit je pense pour certaines
minorités d'abord faire face au sigma la
destination ça fait une charmante exact
qu'est-ce que je m'intéresse beaucoup
dans mon laboratoire c'est de comprendre
les profils de résilience
en plus des profits de résilience d'une
habilité pour comprendre c'est quoi qui
contribuent à la résilience donc est ce
que c'est le soutien social est ce que
c'est les comportements de santé est ce
que c'est les ressources comme une tare
donc j'ai reçu cette année une chaire de
séance qui va s'intéresser à voir la
charge allostatique à plusieurs
générations différents dont moi je
soupçonne que les générations plus
jeunes
la cnu tgbt qu plus n'ont pas les mêmes
gens de stresseurs que le monde 65 ans
donc je m'intéresse beaucoup à
comprendre ces différences de
générations dans charge allostatique
qu'on pourrait avoir puis toute la
recherche que j'ai mentionné jusqu'à
maintenant j'ai jamais mesurer le stigma
vraiment aborder une étude pendant mon
post doc donc vraiment d'être capable
d'avoir une idée du portrait de
l'individu pendant toute leur vie
ça va être vraiment riche pour pour
comprendre tout ce qui ce passe donc
j'ai cette étude-là puis j'ai aussi
plusieurs études qui s'intéressent à
regarder la culte étrange en énorme
binaire en lien avec le stress la charge
allostatique puis à la concussion
donc j'ai utilisé sa rock est lui qui va
avoir un projet qui va axer beaucoup sur
la cognition et les hormones sexuelles
shellac noté lgbt qu plus comparer ou au
monde était au sexuelle fille le but c c
ou de regarder l'accueil me sens où on
sait qu'il ya des différences
homme-femme assez marqué donc servent de
répondre à ces questions là puis j'ai un
autre étudiant
mathias rossi qui s'intéresse plus à un
niveau de réactivité die presse comme
qu'on a fait comme sonné on en parlait
de cortisol est aussi de fonctionnement
cardiovasculaire chez l'adulte et j'ai
eu était qu plus puis le but finalement
avec tout ça c'est pas pour ce très
sainement parce qu'on n'aime pas ça mais
c'est de vraiment comprendre qui est
capable de bien réagir
il réagit un peu avec une réponse
exagérée qui scanne c'est tout influencé
par des facteurs et du jazz ordinaire
exemple mon superviseur pendant mon dock
c'était à jens pruessner quitter un
chercheur un chercheur allemand
actuellement puis lui s'intéressait de
devoir qu'est-ce qui pourrait être lié à
une réponse de stress ou le monde
s'habitue
puis lui a amené du du monde cinq fois
au laboratoire pour ce faire stresser
puis voulez voir à quel point le monde
était capable de se calmer avec le temps
puis qu'est-ce qui a trouvé c'est et que
les hommes qui avaient une estime de soi
assez pauvre assez faible donc c'est un
questionnaire sapeurs de rosine
box-office thing c'est un peu niais sur
ces dix questions de ton estime de soi
séance et menton surf mais était capable
de voir ce qui avait incité ne soit plus
faible avait était incapable de
s'habituer aux strasser puis lui quand
il venu à montréal qui a collaboré
beaucoup avec son lien
il y avait l'image et cérébrales puis a
trouvé que le monde avec un esti ne soit
plus faible et un hippocampe plus petit
qui était relié à une réponse reste plus
augmenté donc même si d'avoir un manque
de style de soi qui affecté par toute
notre vie et a un effet sur ma patte
notre capacité de contextualiser notre
stresseurs donc si c'est trippant comme
résultat puis nous la recherche qu'on
s'intéresse et d'aller plus loin de
vraiment comprendre tous ceux qui vivent
tellement ça serait vraiment fan de
faire des études d'imagerie cérébrale
pour comprendre comment le stigma
affecte la santé de la personne puis
comment la personne répond au stress on
peut stresser le monde dans le scanner
ou si encore une fois c'est fascinant de
voir à quel point tous ces éléments là
sont interreliés type triga quelque
chose puis je vois un effet sur une
autre chose by cc c'est vraiment c'est
sans fin et finalement cette recherche
l'une --une un projet amène un autre âge
exact sur un échelle maintenant je sais
pas de quoi quoi là mais est-ce qu'on
est somme toute avancée dans la
recherche sur le stress on est encore
arriérés par rapport à d'autres
d'autres champs de recherche mais ton
chèque la question est extrêmement flou
le mais est ce que toi tu entrevoir qui
est des grandes grandes découvertes qui
s'en viennent par rapport au stress ou
est-ce que l'essentiel a été découvert
puis lorsqu'il reste si des à peaufiner
certains aspects du sport question c'est
un peu une question existentielle
existentielle pour des gens comme toi
qui sera votre personnage pour répondre
à cette question à un niveau personnel
comme chercheur je suis très bon à
détecter qui est stressé qui va être
stressés qui va donner des problèmes et
qu'est ce que je fais après c'est donc
tout le volet de hockey elle capable de
détecter qui est stressé qui va être
pressé c'est une chose mais qu'est ce
qu'on fait après s'appuie tout ce volet
d'intervention de d'aspect plus clinique
il ya du monde qui en fait mais le
mélange de d'intégrer des biomarqueurs
c'est un peu
il n'y a pas assez qui a été fait
jusqu'à maintenant je pense notre
connaissance du mécanisme de stress puis
la physiologie tout ça s'est super bien
affinity on est rendu à un point on peut
regarder les jeunes puis les épis gêne
puis on est quand même avancé sauf que
ça reste que le stress chronique c'est
un pot pourri pour n'importe quelle
maladie en dessous du ciel non comment
est-ce qu'on peut raffiner nos questions
de recherche pour être capable de mieux
prédire qui va développer quelle maladie
puis je pense ça va être vraiment d'avec
ses perspectives plus individuelle est
capable de voir toutes les
constellations de génétique
d'environnement de coping sueur hedges
dérision ce qu'ils veulent être capable
de savoir quel est le profil d'une
personne du versus un autre une question
plus fondamentale que joueur est capable
de répondre avec ma propre carrière
c'est que est-ce que n'importe quel
stigma va avoir le même art comme on en
reste donc est ce que le raciste va
avoir le même signature biologique ou le
même score ring que l'homophobie
l'homophobie et la transphobie ou le
sexy sous le registre puis moi
personnellement je pense que la réponse
est que ça va être différent
dépendamment sur le sous-groupe qu'on
regarde qui mène jusqu'à l'intérieur de
la communauté lgbt qu plus il ya
énormément de réactions d'un sous groupe
à l'autre puis c'est juste qu'on parlait
de la cnps et étrangers il ya énormément
de réactions donc tu ranges en non-vie
nerfs ce qui 36 cents ce qui on
transfère note
il ya énormément de variation puis je
pense le grand public a su on s'obstine
car il ya trop de l'être dans la réalité
c'est que on veut donner la
représentation puis beaucoup des travaux
que je fais dans mon laboratoire c'est
de rentrer avec la qualité pour faire
des recherches que la leur pour eurent
donc j'ai nommé étudiante cé au filet
laroque qui en études actuellement qui
s'intéressent à faire des entrevues avec
la cugt étrange ans pour leur demander
c'est quoi l'extrait l'industrie sor
pour eux c'est quoi la résilience c'est
quoi la santé c'est quoi le bien-être et
de présenter toutes les méthodologies
qu'on utilise dans la neuroscience
pouvoir est ce que ces approches aligne
avec
vos besoins est ce que vous pensez que
cette ligne de recherche peut amener
quelque chose avoue qu' on est en
recrutement donc s'il ya du monde qui
s'intéresse sa série copions juste
rentré ça aussi on a une étude sur la
cabine puis ça revient plus à ton
commentaire sur le vieillissement est un
concept super intéressant puisque je
veux vraiment mastiquer cette année
c'est crysis capitaine donc la
compétence face à la crise qui c'est un
concept qui a été développé pour parler
vraiment de la qualité gay bisexuelle
transgenre plus vieux qui ont vraiment
fait face à la réalité du voyage placide
est-ce que c'est du monde qui va être
vraiment a largement affectés par la
pandémie ont déjà fait face à quelque
chose de beaucoup plus et donc nous on
s'intéresse ont une étude s'appelle
chrono vareuse price is competitive si
on peut le faire en anglais ou en
français puis on fait un échantillonnage
de tout le monde car à clint on a
jusqu'à maintenant 3200 personnes puis
on s'intéresse à voir vraiment le
mélange de sexe biologique puis le genre
socioculturel puis l'orientation
sexuelle en lien avec la santé mentale
des stratégies d'adaptation pied à la
résilience face à la pandémie qui le but
ça serait pour le monde qui sont à
montréal deux qui accepte d'être
contactés à l'avenir pour d'autres
études les intégrer dans nos études plus
bio pouvoir le stress pendant la
pandémie commence que ça se manifeste
pendant le temps sur le fonctionnement
physiologique ici quelqu'un nous
écoutent et adressée à vouloir
participer à ces études laissent que
c'est possible oui absolument
qu'est ce qu'ils font et ce qu'ils vont
donc le sur facebook ses labos point
césar csa air points juste argileux à ce
théâtre qui m'ont en famille donc ça
c'est notre page facebook puis aussi
montré turquie web un discours par un
discours juste à puis en effet on a
plusieurs études donc il ya si le kayak
mine par mine qui fait une étude sur la
colline
il ya au filet qu'il fallait étude sur
l'acuité transpirons aussi m a fait
d'elle qui fait une étude chez les
les femmes occupent avec femmes pour
comprendre un peu la violence conjugale
puis on a tout ça si ça va tout sur le
facebook je pourrais aussi vous donner
le moyen métrage description ouais c'est
vraiment fascinant moi j'arrête d'être
une dernière question à finir le
championnat plus de sujets je me
questionne sur un mot qu'on entend
beaucoup qui est mot anxiété mettons le
tgp raison que beaucoup de gens
souffrent ou du moins beaucoup de gens
disent à souffrir le tri des grands
celle en citer cinq semaines
annan a en fait c'est quoi la différence
la marque l'anxiété et le stress
donc je pense vous devrez éviter à
marie-france mariage les dires avant
cette fois car ce qu'on fait on se fait
ce que j'ai ri un autre c'est son mari
français ont été étudiées en même temps
avec son air pur marie-france
intéressait beaucoup sur la grille
consolidation des mémoires donc comment
c'est aussi pas compris je vais aller
s'expliquer elle s'intéresse beaucoup à
cette question de porc et d'anxiété
en lien avec le stress piolenc
laboratoire qui s'appelle steve jobs qui
restera ma motion memories qui alors des
études actuellement qui s'intéresse
vraiment à comprendre le mécanisme de
d'anxiété un niveau hétérogène et
intergénérationnelle aussi je pense le
stress comparé à l'anxiété l'anxiété
s'il a un peu la peur d'abord du stress
donc l'accepter vraiment accès plus vers
l'avenir
puis tous les possibilités puis comme
sonné à dix épreuves et stages de notre
évolution de 2 du monde nous y préparer
la projection du futur d'un stress futur
plus que la réponse de stress
immédiatement exactement mais pour du
monde qui ont subi un trauma auparavant
ce c'est sûr que ça tout le temps le
passé le présent et l'avenir
ça devient un peu tout mélanger
c'est définitivement les même genre de
mécanisme mais c'est assez nuancée puis
beaucoup de la recherche que
marie-france effet s'intéresse beaucoup
aux mécanismes qui sont plus relié à
l'adrénaline que le cultuel regarde le
clou si je pense à ça serait la
meilleure personne a vraiment répondu
est-ce que public est ce que tu as à
présent défaut public mélange les deux
oui je continue ou l'absolu comme une
commune compte quelques extraits ci
n'est pas quelqu'un nécessairement ben
ouais ok c'est super merci vernis mat
cette conversation la merci beaucoup
mercier